[موسيقى]
والله منتخب فلسطين يعني منتخب عن جد يعني
سبحان الله بده انه يروح ه انه هالقصص
الحرب يلي صارت وكذا وهو انه بده يفرح
المنتخب يعني انه عاش انه المنتخب
الفلسطيني شفت انت بفلسطين عم يصير الوضع
صعب و يعني صارت 100 شغله وشغله يعني هك
فهن بدهم هالفرحه هي انه فرحه المنتخب
نتمنى كل الخير لمنتخب فلسطين منتخب
فلسطين قدم اداء متصاعد ما شاء الله صحيح
الم كانت
شويه مستواها ضعيف ولكن المباراه الثانيه
كانت احسن نتمل لهم الفوز في المباراه
الثالثه والتاهل ان شاء الله ويصلوا لدور
المتقدمه طبعا في الوضع الراهن اللي تعيشه
فلسطين والماساه الموجوده في غزه اعتقد
انهم نعم قدموا مباراه بطوليه واعتقد لهم
ان شاء الله يعني مستوى مشرف في البطوله
المنتخب الفلسطيني امبارح من اقوى
المنتخبات اللي انا بحضرها بحياتي وان شاء
الله يعني يستمروا وبتحسن اكثر وبيوصل
راوند اوف 16 سمي فاينلز ان شاء الله يا
رب الحمد لله راضين بدائل المنتخب
الفلسطيني لانه مروا في ظروف واقد صعبه
ونتمنى انه يوصلوا لدور ال 16 ان شاء الله
بالظروف اللي عم يمروا فيها اخواتنا
الفلسطينيين و ونحن لازم نكون روح وحده
و وهن اذا فازوا بالكاس الدول العربيه
كلها تعتبر فازت اذا بدي اتوقع لحدا او
بدي اتمنى انه حدا يفوز فهو فلسطين على
الاكيد و وبتمنى انه اح المباراه الاخيره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تبع